And the Humboldt County Fire Safe Council.
Whoops! I was busy looking for the theme song.
[music]
Okay, we have the theme song lined up for Ask Arab Doctor.
It is seven o'clock. This is Redwood Community Radio, KMUD Garberville, KMU Eureka, KLAI Laytonville.
And the views and opinions expressed throughout the broadcast day on Redwood Community Radio
are those of the speakers and not necessarily those of the station staff, underwriters, or volunteers.
Time is made for all sorts of viewpoints on Redwood Community Radio.
And sometimes volunteers and other speakers are just actually saying things that
they believe are other people's opinions, or maybe they're just reading a card.
You never really know. But don't take it personally, the solution to free speech is more free speech.
And, uh, their doctors aren't here yet, but I'm just gonna go ahead and start the theme music here, and we'll work it out.
[music]
And this is your engineer, Michael McCaskill.
Oh, I think they might be here. So I have Dr. Peat online, and we thought we were just gonna do a random show with only him, but somebody might be here.
Dr. Peat. Dr. Peat, do I have you?
I can hardly understand you.
Now, well, I got you back now. Do I have you now?
Yeah, that's better.
Excellent. And can you, you can hear me?
Yeah.
Okay, so why don't you just give a tiny little bit of background, and let me go see what the noise is out there.
And so, listeners, we're having a special show tonight where, unless Andrew and Sarah show up in a few minutes, we're just gonna be having an open call-in session to ask Dr. Peat your questions.
So if you have a question for Dr. Peat, you can go ahead and call 923-3911 right now, and Dr. Peat is just gonna do a tiny little bit of an intro.
Okay, I've been doing a nutrition consulting largely for the last 40 or 50 years, but I'm recently getting more interested in immunology.
It's been 40 years since I taught, of course, in immunology, but because of the pandemic, I started reading more about it and looking at the way the history and the development of corporate and government science,
the way those influences have distorted the understanding of immunology, even in these 40 years since I was studying it and teaching it for a while.
Excellent, and so that wasn't all the Murray's showing up out there, so I'm gonna just throw the phone lines open now as your chance to ask Dr. Peat about any questions you have.
I know we have a lot of listeners around the world who are not used to being able to call in until half an hour in or so, but do call 707-923-3911 if you would like to ask any questions of Dr. Peat.
So, I could start out with kind of a juicy question, perhaps. There's been, you know, a lot of, you know, sort of conflict around COVID-19 and vaccination and, you know, how beneficial it could be and whatnot.
But also some questions about just how effective it is for really at-risk people. So, could you maybe give some herbological or dietary sorts of things which you think would be beneficial for everybody to do, regardless of whether they're vaccinated or not,
in order to make sure that the vaccines work the very best for them, or whatever tactics they're using work the very best for them.
And hopefully people will call 923-3911 and ask questions.
Vitamin D is probably the single most important thing for Americans considering the average American diet.
The majority of people are far below the optimal level of vitamin D. And even though the establishment still believes that the lower end of the normal range is adequate when you look at degenerative diseases, heart disease,
even some fairly rare things like scleroderma, the whole range of degenerative system failure is associated with fairly low vitamin D deficiency.
And something that has kept more doctors from prescribing vitamin D is that there have periodically been scares about the dangers of taking too much vitamin D.
It's true that if you take a million units or so after a while, you'll start getting hypercalcemia and calcification of soft tissues.
But the most common cause of calcification of the soft tissues is actually for my deficiency of vitamin D with aging and failure of the kidneys.
Calcification of the kidney tissue and blood vessels in general becomes the lethal problem.
And the mechanism why kidney failure is associated with calcification is that it's also associated with extreme vitamin D deficiency and an excess of parathyroid hormone.
They've seen that even removing the parathyroid glands can alleviate some of the symptoms of calcification from kidney failure.
But just supplementing a moderate amount of vitamin D, like 5,000 units a day for an adult, can be enough if you have calcium in your diet.
It can be enough to lower the parathyroid hormone and lowering the parathyroid hormone makes you put your calcium into the bones where it should go and keeping it out of the soft tissues.
And so I know that people can get vitamin D from sunlight, and it really depends on what your skin tone is, how much time you would have to spend out there.
But are there other things that you get from the sunlight in addition to vitamin D that might make that a better source of vitamin D than just taking a pill or eating a vitamin D-rich food?
Yeah, because the light that penetrates the ultraviolet is very superficial.
It acts on the skin cells themselves.
But the visible light, especially the orange and red light, penetrates very deeply.
If you hold your hand up and look at the sunlight shining through it, it's very red on the shaded side showing that the red light easily penetrates the thickness of your skin.
In the dark room, you can see the penetration of your whole body with that same red transmission effect.
And the red light is an anti-free radical protection.
It, in effect, quenches excited electrons and reverses the effect of the free radical damage done by ultraviolet light.
So a tanning bed, which is only infrared and some visible, will produce more aging effects than sunlight of the same tanning effect.
So you meant it's more UV and some visible?
Yeah, the UV by itself causes free radical damage and aging of the skin.
But when it's sunlight, the quenching effect of the red and orange light detoxifies much of the free radical damage done by the ultraviolet.
Well, I hate to give advice to technological solution types, but perhaps all tanning beds should include red LEDs as well.
I think so.
So we do have a caller. That person called 707-923-3911. And since the herb doctors aren't here, I can't necessarily really engineer, so I definitely cannot talk to you.
People always want to talk to me during this show. I'm not talking to any of you.
You're just going to call 923-3911, and you'll hear a click, and you'll hear a couple clicks, and just listen on the phone, because then you'll hear another click, and we'll say you're on the air.
And if you're listening on the radio, you'll be eight seconds behind, and we'll hang up on you.
So here is our first caller. Caller, you are on the air.
Hi, Dr. Peat. My name is James. I'm in Arizona. And I've subscribed to your newsletter for the last couple years.
And in one of the first newsletters about the coronavirus, you said cellular excitation is required for a coronavirus infection.
And I remember having an odd headache one day in the December 2019, January 2020 period, and I've later reconstructed that this virus was spreading in my community in that period.
So I was wondering if a person is not cellular excited, would they just not be exposed, and they wouldn't develop antibodies or a T cell response because they just don't need it?
If your cells are already in a weakened, excitable state, they are the most susceptible to viral infection.
And if the cell is stable, even if it's infected by a virus, it will turn off the process rather than letting the virus propagate.
And the things that are known to be protective against the infection or development of the disease include just about all of the known safe anti-inflammatory substances are known to protect against the infection and alleviate its worst symptoms.
Aspirin, naproxen, progesterone, vitamin D has a calming effect, quieting effect on cells.
The antihistamines and anti-serotonin drugs, the angiotensin, blood pressure treatments such as Losartan and Candesartan are protective.
And in an earlier show, you talked about how the proteins are acidifying, like phosphorus gets metabolized into phosphoric acid.
And you talked about the importance of having adequate alkaline minerals in your cells, so the body wouldn't have to sacrifice itself or sacrifice protein.
Yeah, that happens in the kidneys. The kidneys will break down protein to balance the V8, but the phosphate itself has an excitatory action.
When ATP is breaking down and doing the cell work, it liberates the inorganic phosphate, and the inorganic phosphate has an excitatory effect when it can get attached back to form ATP again, the cell relaxes.
So ATP's effect is relaxing, making it stable against infection, and an excess of free phosphate antagonizes the stabilizing effect of vitamin D and calcium and puts cells into the excited and more excitable state of being susceptible to infections.
The other acidic mineral is sulfur. How does sulfur and sulfuric acid play into imbalance?
Yeah, those are pretty safe. If you add too much sulfur to your diet, you'll disturb the absorption of minerals.
For example, you can block the formation of pigment by cutting down your assimilation of copper if you have too much sulfur in your diet.
But otherwise, sulfuric foods are reasonably safe. You can dispose of it as the acid.
Okay, and lastly, my friend's 70-something-year-old husband had the virus. He had a pretty bad experience.
He survived in spite of the treatment of the hospital, but I guess he's gone back to the hospital recently, and they've got him on diuretics.
So what's good to help somebody who has sort of a long COVID autoimmune condition where it's hitting their kidneys?
Mentioning the diuretics brings up perspective on what's actually happening in the infection.
In the first weeks of the pandemic, a doctor in New York, actually two doctors in New York, both came up with the same realization that the symptoms of COVID were essentially the same as the symptoms of high-altitude sickness.
People who don't adapt to very high-altitude develop edema of the lungs and general inflammatory systems of failure of the tissues to use oxygen properly.
And the treatment that they recognized as established for mountain sickness, one of the treatments is a diuretic acetazolamide,
which restores the level of carbon dioxide in your body, and the acidity is a quieting, sedating effect that also goes with causing the tissue cells to give up excess water.
And the carbon dioxide itself has many calming, quieting, sedative effects.
The calcium channel blockers were their other suggestions for both mountain sickness and the COVID infection.
And one of these doctors, Cameron Kyle Seidel, offered his perception of the nature of the oxidative problems which justifies the use of acetazolamide, which is a carbonic anhydrase inhibitor.
And it turns out that the calcium channel blockers are also carbonic anhydrase inhibitors, which contribute to retaining more carbon dioxide in your body.
Seidel's observation was that the inflamed lung, the thickness between the capillary in the lung and the air chamber, is increased by inflammation
and actually by a deficiency of carbon dioxide, contributes to the thickening, making it harder for gases to diffuse through this thickened pathway from air to blood.
And it happens that besides cutting off the entry of oxygen into the capillaries, it happens that carbon dioxide diffuses much faster through liquid than oxygen does.
And Kyle Seidel observed that the breathing problem is because you're not just not getting enough oxygen, but you're losing carbon dioxide very fast.
And when your carbon dioxide level goes down, oxygen sticks too firmly to the hemoglobin, increases the blood's affinity for oxygen to the point that your tissue cells are starving for oxygen despite some oxygen being there.
It helps to some extent to get more oxygen in, but it's really the deficiency of carbon dioxide in the blood that keeps the oxygen from being delivered as needed.
So I've heard complaints about masks increasing the carbon dioxide level that people are breathing in. Assuming they're still getting enough oxygen, might that actually be a bonus?
Yeah, that's what the acetazolamide and calcium channel blockers are doing. It's making you retain the carbon dioxide more efficiently.
And would drinking carbonated drinks help increase your carbon dioxide? I mean, I'm going to get around to the beer cure.
Yeah, and even adding baking soda to water, marathon runners and bicyclers have found that for them, if they're going to have to bicycle for 30 miles or something, if they put a tablespoon of baking soda in the glass of water, their endurance is greatly increased.
Apparently by the provision of that bonus of carbon dioxide.
And the reason they were getting 60 to 80% mortality in the hospitals that used the forced ventilating machines, putting a tube into their throat and pumping oxygen, those hospitals were having terribly high mortality.
I'm approaching 100% of the intubated people were joining hospitals, simply passively, giving them a little extra oxygen had close to zero mortality.
The excess of oxygen was injuring the lungs, increasing the problem of diffusing both of the gases by driving out too much carbon dioxide, the pumped in oxygen was making the problem worse.
And that brings up the, the subject of garbage and I haven't heard of any hospital which is consistently using that as treatment, but it had been a treatment from the 1930s up until the mid 1950s hospitals, all over the world, recognize that using
typically a 5% carbon dioxide, 95% oxygen mixture, rather than pure oxygen, prevented the damage to the lungs that you get with pure oxygen.
And the reason hasn't been used since about 1955. Nothing happened scientifically to explain why it was curing people, or why it shouldn't be used, but a committee government medical committee in England said that just doesn't fit our opinion
of how respiration works. You should not use any carbon dioxide in asphyxiated people because they declared that asphyxia is synonymous with having too much carbon dioxide.
They were simply talking through their hats. They had no evidence to support it, but since that official government statement that hospitals should not use carbon from its use dropped off all around the world.
And the people who are studying it show that it does prevent labor, lung damage, and has an anti-inflammatory effect in the lungs and other tissues.
I found a translation of a paper in German from 1904. This paper in German said sometimes a person doesn't need oxygen to skim a little whiff of carbon dioxide, and it improved their oxygen uptake. Have you heard of that?
Not that particular paper to remember. That's the way it works. The very mechanism, it's recognized that the hemoglobin is acidified by the binding of oxygen,
but the more acidic carbon dioxide molecule shifts the pH and oxygen affinity of the hemoglobin. It outcompetes the oxygen for combining with the hemoglobin.
So that was around the time that they were demonstrating the necessity for carbon dioxide to release oxygen to the tissues.
And then when the blood returns to the lungs with a high concentration of oxygen, in that situation the carbon dioxide is displaced by the extreme concentration of oxygen.
And the mechanism by which carbon dioxide binds to the hemoglobin forms a chemical bond called the carbamenal group.
And that, for some reason, the textbooks have been willing to mention that bit of chemistry, that the amino group of certain amino acids that have a side group of amine or the end of a molecule, the amino end of a protein molecule.
They recognize that chemically combines with carbon dioxide forming a different protein effect, chemically modified protein.
And although the respiration books are happy to mention that as just a sidelight of the process, it happens that all of our body proteins display some of these same amino groups or side chains of amino acids.
And that carbon dioxide is going to similarly bind every place in the body that there is protein. Carbon dioxide is going to modify those proteins.
And so the toxicity of losing your proper level of carbon dioxide by going to very high altitude without adaptation or by hyperventilating or by being artificially ventilated with pure oxygen,
all of those things are not only inflaming your lungs, but in effect are inflaming every protein in your body.
So we have another caller. They called 923-3911. If you would like to ask a question of Dr. Peat, do call 923-3911 and listen for the clicks and just stay on the line.
And then someone will say, "You are on the air and you'll be on the air." That's you.
So it is. This is Ross. I'm calling you from White Thorne. And I'd like to ask Dr. Peat what he thinks of a substance called carnitine, L-carnitine, for example.
I read about it in a book by Dr. Nick Lane, who is a British physician.
And could you turn your phone off in the background there? I mean, sorry, your radio off. It's repeating in the background there.
Yeah, how's that? Excellent. Dr. Peat, carnitine.
Yeah, I'll take it out. I'll take the answer off the air.
Okay. It's active in helping you oxidize fats. So in ordinary metabolism, it's essential.
But when you're under stress, the products of oxidizing pure fat will produce less carbon dioxide in proportion to the oxygen used.
And so in stressful situations, such as it can affect a failing heart, carnitine, by increasing your ability to oxidize fats, can actually increase the problem of oxygen availability
because of producing less carbon dioxide per oxygen consumed.
And in the 1990s, people experimented, finding that if you could keep cells oxidizing glucose, they produce more carbon dioxide per oxygen consumed.
And so the effect is to make metabolism more efficient, reduce inflammation by the increased carbon dioxide, leave more oxygen available, and change the affinity of hemoglobin, making the oxygen more available.
And the first name of this chemical increased the ability to use glucose rather than fat.
It was called mildronate at first, and more recently they are calling it meldonium, and athletes are using it.
And I think it has disqualified some famous athletes because it improves their endurance noticeably.
It's probably similar to the mechanism of the endurance athletes taking sodium bicarbonate, producing more CO2 with the pro-oxygen effect.
Can athletes get busted for doping with sodium bicarbonate? Is that illegal?
I think sodium bicarbonate is still legal, but meldonium or mildronate I think are banned.
The way mildronate works is to bypass carnitine. So even though carnitine is a normal essential thing for burning fats under stress, meldonium or mildronate can bypass it and get glucose to the cells.
Okay, we have two callers. So the first of the two callers, this is you. You're on the air.
Hello, Dr. Peat. I was curious about whey. Now I seem to crave cottage cheese because of the whey, and I was wondering if you could talk about that and what it does.
And I'll take my answer off the air as well.
I didn't hear the first part of the question.
Yes, I said, can you hear me now? Yeah. Okay. I was asking, I seem to crave cottage cheese, and I think it might be the way that I crave.
And I'll take my answer off the air. I was hoping you could discuss whey and what it does and all of the dynamics involved. Thank you.
The physiology of consuming any of the milk products, both the whey and the casein fractions have multiple beneficial effects that are approaching hormonal
and immune-promoting, psychoactive and so on. The protein quality of both of them, one of their virtues is that they are deficient in iron but have almost all of the other nutrients associated with them.
And iron happens to be one of the main risks of any stress. It tends to make iron toxic and increase your susceptibility to infections so that the body under stress has mechanisms to get rid of iron.
But milk foresees that, and so the milk provides all of the helpful nutrients that are very deficient in iron.
And the high calcium content of milk products, the calcium works along with vitamin D to suppress a parathyroid hormone.
And these peptides and proteins of milk and casein and whey fractions both contain anti-inflammatory substances intrinsically, but they also, just because of the calcium, lower parathyroid hormone
and the parathyroid hormone is one of our basic pro-inflammatory problems. It lowers our cellular energy production but also increases many of our basic inflammation producing processes, cytokines and so on.
Okay, we have another caller. Caller, you're on the air.
Yes, I have a question for Dr. Peat. Just to see if there's any nutritional advice for people with arrhythmia, specifically with PVCs or premature ventricle contractions.
It's more on the electrical side of the heart. They're having like thousands of them every day with no other symptoms, just some of the extra skipped feet.
One of the basic medical recommendations for a variety of arrhythmias is to avoid hypothyroidism, but in reality, that might be an instantaneous effect.
You can provoke an arrhythmia with a sudden dose of thyroid, but a chronic lack of thyroid hormone can create preconditions for having arrhythmia, including nutritional balances and increases of stress hormones.
And an imbalance, for example, between the stress steroids, including cortisol and estrogen, and the anti-stress, quieting, pregnant alone progesterone, and to some extent the androgens.
Okay, and do you know if there's any association also with histamine around arrhythmia? Because I also have very itchy skin, and it's something that I don't know if there's an association there.
I didn't hear the last part.
Yeah, I just wanted to know if histamine could be associated with arrhythmia, because my other symptom is with itchy skin.
If what is associated with arrhythmia?
If histamines.
Oh, yeah, it's one of the serotonin and histamine are closely connected with changing the heart rhythm.
So might there be a dietary recommendation to help be antihistamine yet supporting the heart?
Yeah, the milk products are among their effects as an antihistamine, anti-inflammatory effect, and a good balance of all of the essential nutrients needed for balancing your thyroid function.
Seafood at least once a week is helpful for the trace minerals.
Yes, I do enjoy quite a bit of seafood like shellfish, especially, yes, and maybe that's my body telling me that I need a little more on that, but thank you.
Okay, and the calls, the lines are empty if you'd like to call and ask Dr. Peat a question at 933911, please do.
And that fellow's last comment about shellfish and maybe it's his body craving that.
Could you maybe, I don't know that you know anything about this at all, but could you have any ideas about how the body, how cravings work and how the body might know what is good for you,
or maybe try to teach people things that might be symptoms to them that a food's really working for them?
Yeah, there have been quite a few studies, mostly in animals, but some people have tested it on their kids, noticing that their kids will sometimes seem to have a completely crazy deranged appetite,
wanting only one food for several meals in a row, but when they've looked at their food choices, even though they might momentarily seem crazy,
when they add them up over a period of a week or two, it turns out that their choices were ending up for a proper balance of nutrients.
And so they've tested that on animals and created a deficiency in a particular vitamin or certain amino acids,
and find that the animal knows how to, over a very broad range of deficiencies, they will ignore a food that might seem, in general, good, but that's deficient in the nutrients that they particularly need
and concentrate on one food that's richest in what they need, and it turns out that there are only two or three of the essential amino acids that are taken as signals,
and so if they make a food deficient in one of the amino acids that doesn't act as a guide and attractant, they find that the animal no longer makes the right choice.
In nature, those rare patterns of deficiency don't occur, so that the signal of a deficiency or adequacy, those are always detectable,
so animals essentially invariably, given a choice of natural foods, will pick out the ones that are nutritionally balanced meeting their needs.
And we've got two callers. I hope you all are listening on the phone instead of all the radio, because here's the first of you.
This one is you. Please speak up.
Did you listen on your radio instead of the phone? Oh, well, here's the next person. Let's see if they're listening on the phone.
Caller, this is you. Caller. Hello, caller. You didn't put the phone down and go listen on the radio, too, because it's going to take many seconds for you to figure it out and get over here.
Oh, my God. No, sorry, that was operator error. Caller, you can laugh at me now in public because I pressed the wrong button. Caller, now this one's you.
OK, is this me? This is you. Yes, you haven't laughed at me yet for operator error. OK, good. Here comes another.
So I had to my house deliver a pile of wood chips and turned out that it's full of Aspergillus fungus. And when I was shoveling it, there were all these spores coming out of it.
And I should have, it was like a smoke and I should have had a mask on. I held my breath instead and I didn't know really what it was.
And I ended up getting very close to it and getting kind of a whiff of it. And then I was wheezing a couple hours later and now I've learned that it can live in my lungs.
And so I want to know what kind of antifungal or anything like that, if you've got any advice about getting fungus out of my lungs.
Probably your lungs are going to take care of it. And I'll take it offline. It never hurts to make sure your vitamin D is adequate.
And I mentioned that vitamin D for Americans is the most important immune-supporting nutrient. But in the world in general, vitamin A and zinc are rivals for protection of the membranes and the direct immunity
to not only germs, but mechanical or chemical irritants.
And so a good diet with anti-inflammatory foods besides milk products, the citrus fruits are very rich in flavonoids, which are anti-inflammatory and pro-immunity.
And coffee is another good source of anti-inflammatory substances such as quercetin as well as some nutrients.
Okay, we have another caller here. Caller, this one is you.
Holly, I was wondering the difference between vitamin D and D3. Which one is the one that we should be taking?
Vitamin D and D3, did you say? Yeah. Yeah, D3 is the normal one that we make when we're in the sunlight.
And so when we eat it, it works the same chemically as the one we make in the sunlight. But some of the products on the market are vitamin D2.
And that is metabolized slightly differently and doesn't have all of the good protective effects of vitamin D3.
And then there are some medical products that are, for example...
So D3 is the one we should be taking to boost our immunity? That's the number one supplement you were talking about?
Yeah, vitamin D3 is the usual supplement. If you're in a medical context, you might hear people talk about the Telsipi trial.
You don't want the trial. And some people confuse that with the vitamin D3.
It's a Colecalciferol.
So D3 is the one. And we've got another caller.
Okay, thank you.
Caller, you're on the air with Dr. Peat.
I feel like I have kind of a brain fog type issue. And I'm not sure if it's associated with... I'm pretty sure I had COVID about a year ago.
But I don't know if it's genetic or from COVID or just my age. I'm 54, my diet. I wondered if you had recommendations for dietary or herbal supplements that maybe might help me besides caffeine, which is what I realized.
I couldn't hear the first part of it. What was the problem?
It had to do with feelings of brain fog. And I'm not sure why I have that. But I just wondered if you had nutritional or herbal recommendations that might help boost my mental acuity.
I couldn't hear the particular problem.
I think it was brain fog and possibly as a long COVID symptom, if that's what I'm gathering correctly.
Oh, that's correct. I'll listen up here. I'm having a hard time hearing Dr. Peat, too. Thank you.
Yeah, the brain fog goes with low energy production and low carbon dioxide.
And the vitamin B1 is a natural equivalent to acetazolamide and the calcium channel blockers in being an inhibitor of carbonic anhydrase, helping to raise your carbon dioxide.
And it's often the quickest way to clear up brain fog and get your mental energy back.
But all of the anti-inflammatory things, thyroid hormone, vitamin D, calcium progesterone, anti-inflammatory things such as fruit juice.
Okay, we have one more caller. Maybe we could squeeze in one more after this, if this one's quick. But maybe not. And caller, you are on the air.
Hi, Dr. Peat, I've had diabetes for many years and my blood sugar was getting worse and worse.
And I read about and have now investigated intermittent fasting.
And I wonder if you could give me your thoughts on the process of intermittent fasting.
So far it seems to be bringing my blood sugar way down and I wanted to hear what you had to say.
It will make your blood sugar go down, but anything that you can call fasting is going to be putting you under stress.
And the long range thing that corrects chronic diabetes is to get your polyunsaturated fats lower to completely eliminate them from your diet as far as possible.
And you use the butter, for example, for cooking rather than any of the liquid vegetable oils because the polyunsaturated fats are specifically toxic to your insulin producing tissues
and create resistance in your tissues and damage the ability to oxidize sugar.
And they have no essential need. There's no benefit that will be lost by eating a completely saturated fat component of your diet.
And carbohydrates, if they're taken in the consistent way, it happens that glucose is constantly activating stem cells in your pancreas to restore the ability to produce insulin.
And it's the polyunsaturated fats stored in your tissues or coming direct from your food that will keep destroying or damaging your insulin producing cells.
Excellent. Well, thank you so much for the information and thanks to Andrew and Sarah Murray for letting me sit in, if that's what I was doing.
And thank you so much, Dr. Peat, for being flexible and giving your information, sharing your knowledge with the Cayman community.
Is there a little quick wrap up you'd like to do? Let people know where they can find more information about you and there's some stuff of you on the Internet and stuff.
Yeah, my website is raypeet.com and the newsletter, the subscribing information is raypeetsnewsletter@gmail.com.
Excellent. Thank you so much for joining us.
Okay, thank you.
Bye-bye.
Yes, I have Dr. Peat's phone number.
I have Dennis from the Pilot's Lounge phone number too, but probably more of you are more jealous of me having Dr. Peat's phone number.
Luckily, I had his number and I was able to salvage and ask your herb doctor.
If you would like to be an underwriter on Ask Your Herb Doctor, especially if you had a product or service which was health or nutrition related, you could call the Cayman Business Office 923-2513 during office hours next week.
And arrange to be an underwriter and right now I would be telling the Cayman listening community about your product or service.
Thank you so much for listening to us and get ready. It's time to step out on a wing and a prayer.
This is Redwood Community Radio, KMUD Garberville, KMU-E Eureka, KLA, Laytonville. It is 7.59.
Oops, I'll do that with the music down.
KMUD Garberville, KMU-E Eureka, KLA, Laytonville. It is 8 o'clock. Time to step out on a wing and a prayer.